♪ ♪
>> ANY COUNTRY THAT DEVALUES
THEIR CURRENCY IN ORDER TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE UNITED STATES
AND ITS WORKERS WILL BE MET
VERY, VERY SHARPLY.
AND THAT INCLUDES TARIFFS AND
TAXES FOR THEIR GOODS COMING
INTO THE COUNTRY.
WE WILL BE IMPOSING TARIFFS ON
STEEL IMPORTS AND TARIFFS ON
ALUMINUM IMPORTS AND YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS HAPPEN.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE EXPANSIONS
OF THE COMPANIES.
25% ON STEEL AND 10% FOR
ALUMINUM.
IT WILL BE FOR A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT ANNOUNCING
TARIFFS, NOT MAKING IT OFFICIAL
UNTIL NEXT WEEK.
THE MARKETS GOT SPOOKED BY ALL
OF THAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE SURPRISED
IT CAME OUT TODAY.
WHEN IT COMES TO STEEL IMPORTS,
THE UNITED STATES IS THE WORLD'S
LARGEST STEEL IMPORTER.
26.9 MILLION METRIC TONS OF
STEEL IMPORTED INTO THE U.S. IN
2017.
HERE IS THE INTERESTING THING.
IF YOU THOUGHT THIS WAS ALL
ABOUT CHINA, THE TOP TEN SOURCES
OF STEEL IMPORTS IN THE U.S.,
THEY ARE NOT CHINA.
NUMBER ONE IS CANADA.
BRAZIL, SOUTH KOREA, TEN OF THE
TOP 12 ARE ALLIES OF THE U.S.
ALUMINUM, CHINA'S NUMBER THREE.
CANADA, 43%, THE NUMBER ONE
EXPORTER INTO THE U.S.
OF ALUMINUM.
WHAT ABOUT THIS AND WHERE IT
HEADS?
LET'S BRING THE PANEL.
MIKE ALLEN, COFOUNDER OF AXIOS.
KATIE PAVLICH, MO ELLEITHEE.
MY, THERE'S A BIG BATTLE ON THIS
ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT CAMPAIGNED ON IT.
SHOULDN'T BE A SURPRISE.
BUT ROLLING IT OUT LIKE THIS
WAS.
>> IT WAS A SURPRISE, NOT JUST
TO THE MARKETS.
IT WAS A SHOCK INSIDE.
I CAN'T OVERSTATE HOW UNUSUAL IT
IS FOR WHITE HOUSE AIDES, A
COUPLE HOURS BEFORE A BIG
PRESIDENTIAL EVENT, TO HAVE NO
IDEA.
THIS TELLS YOU HOW THEY THINK
COMPARED TO HOW THE PRESIDENT
THINKS.
THEY WERE TELLING US HE CAN'T DO
THIS.
THE PAPERWORK ISN'T DONE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SAYING HE
WANTS TO DO THIS.
AXIOS HAS REPORTED, SAYING BRING
ME MY TARIFFS.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT GETTING WHAT
HE WANTED AND THE CHART YOU
SHOWED IS PART OF THE ARGUMENT
THAT AIDES HAVE BEEN MAKING TO
DELAY, TRY TO PUT IT OFF, BUY
SOME TIME.
>> Bret: GARY COHN IS ONE OF
THOSE PUSHING BACK.
HAS A SUPPORTER EIGHT IN WILBUR
ROSS IN CONVERSE, ROBERT
LIGHTHIZER AND HE CAMPAIGNED ON
IT.
SOME OF THE STATES AFFECTED.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION IS
GAMBLING ON THE IDEA THAT THE
ENDS WILL JUSTIFY THE MEANS.
THEY KNOW IT'S A BIG RISK.
SHOWS THAT TARIFFS AREN'T ALWAYS
GOOD FOR THE UNITED STATES, AND
NOT WHEN IT COMES TO PUTTING
TAXES ON OUR ALLIES.
THIS MIGHT BE ABOUT CHINA.
WE NEED TO FIND WAYS TO PUNISH
THEM.
THEY STEAL OUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY, THEY CHEAT ON THE
ECONOMY.
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE OF PUSHBACK
ON THE WAY THE PRESIDENT IS
GOING ABOUT THIS BUT I THINK WE
HAVE TO GIVE IT TIME.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO HAS
BLOWN THINGS OUT BEFORE.
PEOPLE HAVE PANICKED.
ISSUES STATEMENTS OF COMBINATION
ISSUES STATEMENTS OF COMBINATIO
CONDEMNATION.
THIS IS A BIG RISK FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT WILL HAVE TO
WAIT AND SEE.
>> Bret: ROBERT LIGHTHIZER AND
SENATOR SASSE EARLIER.
>> THE RESPONSE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO START A TRADE WAR IS
NONSENSE.
WE HAVE A VERY, VERY IMBALANCED
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA.
THE PRESIDENT IS BEYOND ENGAGE.
HE CARES ABOUT JOBS AND WAGES.
POLITICS NEVER COMES UP.
WHEN HE IS NOT THINKING ABOUT
JOBS AND WAGES, ITS WAGES AND
JOBS.
>> TRADE IS GREAT FOR AMERICA.
TRADE IS GREAT FOR AMERICAN
FAMILIES ARE NO TRADE WAR IS
EVER WORKED.
WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE AMERICA
1930 AGAIN.
LEE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF
AMERICA DON'T WANT TO BE DRAFTED
NO TRADE WAR.
IF YOU OWN A STEEL MILL TODAY
WAS GREAT FOR YOU.
IF YOU CONSUME STEEL, AND EVERY
AMERICAN FAMILY AT THE STORAGE
MIGHT BUY SOMETHING THAT HAS
DIFFERENT METALS IN IT, TODAY IS
A BAD DAY FOR YOU.
>> Bret: THIS IS 2 FOR 2 FOR
DEMOCRATS WHEN IT COMES TO GUN
CONTROL AND THIS ISSUE.
HOW DOES IT STAND?
>> I DON'T KNOW YOU WILL FIND
UNANIMITY AND THE DEMOCRATS ON
THIS.
THERE ARE DEMOCRATS WHO SUPPORT
FREE TRADE AND WHO ARE NERVOUS
ABOUT A TRADE WAR.
I THOUGHT SENATOR SASSE'S POINT
WAS INTERESTING.
IF YOU ARE A STEEL MANUFACTURER,
YOU ARE HAPPY.
IF YOU ARE A STEEL CONSUMER,
HOLD ON TO YOUR HORSES.
THINGS ARE ABOUT TO GET ROCKY.
THE LAST TIME WE HAD ONE OF
THESE, IN 2002 WHEN
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH IMPOSED
TARIFFS ON STEEL, WE SOUGHT NOT
JUST THREATS OF RETALIATION FROM
THE E.U. ON THE AMERICAN
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR.
AMERICAN FARMERS OUGHT TO BE
SWEATING RIGHT NOW.
BUT YOU ALSO SAW MANUFACTURING
PLANTS THAT ARE CONSUMERS OF
STEEL PUT OUT REPORTS TALKING
ABOUT HOW THEY HAD TO LAY OFF
200,000 AMERICAN WORKERS AND
JACK UP THEIR PRICES.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
POLITICAL ALLIANCES FOR AND
AGAINST THIS.
>> Bret: TARIFFS IN THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION LASTED 21 MONTHS.
THEY WERE PULLED DOWN FOR THAT
VERY REASON.
THREATS OF RETALIATION.
DOES THIS GO THROUGH?
DOES THIS SEE A LOT OF
RESISTANCE ON CAPITOL HILL?
>> THE IMPORTANT THING TO WATCH,
AND YOU'RE 12 COUNTRIES THERE
TELLS THE STORY, OVER THE NEXT
WEEK, THERE'S GOING TO BE A
FEROCIOUS BATTLE IN THE
WEST WING AND ELSEWHERE FOR
WHICH ARE GOING TO BE THE
CARVE OUTS.
PRESIDENT DID THIS.
IF YOU ARE AGAINST IT, YOU
CONSIDER IT A CRIME OF
OPPORTUNITY.
THE PRESIDENT HAD A COUPLE AIDES
WHO WERE FOR IT AND THEY PUSHED
IT THROUGH.
NOW THEY WILL TRY TO SWEAT IT
OUT, DO WE TAKE OUT CANADA,
EUROPE?
IT'S GOING TO MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
>> Bret: YOU CAN ALMOST HEAR
THE PHONE'S RINGING ON K STREET.
GET OVER THERE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT GUNS AND WE
HAVE A MONTAGE, SOME OF THE
SOUND FROM THE PAST DAY AND A
HALF.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID A LOT OF
THINGS RIGHT YESTERDAY.
IN SIMILAR MEETINGS WE HAVE BEEN
DISAPPOINTED IN THE PAST.
>> I WILL TAKE ALL THE HEAT YOU
WANT TO GIVE ME.
I WILL TAKE THE HEAT OFF
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
>> THAT CANNOT HAPPEN ON GUNS.
>> I KNOW THAT IF THE
COMPREHENSIVE BILL CAME TO THE
FLOOR ON BACKGROUND CHECKS, IT
WOULD WIN.
>> THERE ARE THINGS THAT HAVE
WIDESPREAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THAT WE CAN ACT ON AND GET PAST.
>> A WEEK WILL GO BY.
ANOTHER WEEK, ANOTHER WEEK
ANOTHER WEEK.
PEOPLE WILL BE ON OTHER THINGS.
WE CAN'T LET THAT HAPPEN.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT HAS
GOTTEN PRAISE FOR THESE OPEN
MEETINGS.
THE ONE ON GUNS YESTERDAY REALLY
RAISED SOME EYEBROWS, ESPECIALLY
FROM THE NRA AND GUN SUPPORTERS.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO START.
FOR THE PRESIDENT TO SIT THERE
AND PUNCH THE NRA IN THE NOSE
MULTIPLE TIMES, WHILE
DOWNPLAYING THEIR IMPORTANCE,
SAYING HE DOESN'T NECESSARILY
NEED THEM AND THEN FOR HIM TO
HAVE DIANNE FEINSTEIN,
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN, SHE
WAS JUMPING FOR JOY OUT OF HER
SEAT, RESUBMIT HER BAN ON A
NUMBER OF SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS.
I HAVE TALKED TO A NUMBER OF NRA
MEMBERS SAYING WE ARE WILLING TO
GIVE THE PRESIDENT A PASS ON THE
NUMBER OF THINGS BUT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND CAVING TO THE
EMOTIONS OF THIS, THE DO
SOMETHING ATTITUDE, WHEN THIS
WAS A FAILURE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
IN THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
IT'S A REDLINE FOR US.
>> Bret: I AM CYNICAL ON THE
POLITICAL THING.
THE POSITIONING OF
DIANNE FEINSTEIN COULD BE
TROUBLE FOR HER.
HOW CLOSE ARE YOU TO
DONALD TRUMP?
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF PLAYS.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THIS PLAYS
INTO PRIMARY POLITICS.
I AM OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER WHEN
ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE TALKING
POINTS AGAINST BARACK OBAMA AND
HILLARY CLINTON AND BILL CLINTON
WAS THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
COME AND ILLEGALLY SEIZE YOUR
GOODS.
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SAT THERE AND SAID
SEIZE THE GUNS FIRST.
DUE PROCESS LATER.
A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT HAS GONE
FURTHER TALKING ABOUT ILLEGALLY
SEIZING FIREARMS THAN ANY
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT HAS.
>> Bret: MIKE, TEN SECONDS.
DO SOMETHING GET DONE?
>> IT DOES BUT MINIMALIST.
THE CALCULATION IS THAT WHATEVER
CREDIT REPUBLICANS WOULD GET FOR
GOING FURTHER ON GUNS THAN THEY
HAVE IN THE PAST, THEY WOULD PAY
MORE OF A PRICE WITH THEIR OWN
PEOPLE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A COUPLE
THINGS.